Melissa Rycroft welcomes baby number  three it's exciting the proud mama  showed off her new bundle of joy on  Instagram Thursday  sweetly gazing into her baby boy's eyes  she revealed his adorable name in the  caption writing case and Jack welcome to  the world little one the 33 year old and  her hubby ty got married in 2009 and  welcomed their first child Ava in 2011  and their second Beckett in 2014  how old are you today the Dancing with  the Stars champ hosts tons of cute snaps  with her family on social media and  documented her pregnancy by sharing  hilarious pics of her growing bump  just days after Beckett was born melissa  gushed to ET about how much she loves  being a mom oh I just I love it I love  every moment and even when I'm tired  it's like I wake up and I look at this  little face going how can you be upset  you know when you see that face